[Music]
mark cuban
is a billionaire he owns the dallas
mavericks the nba team like other nba
owners mark cuba makes a lot of his
money
in china and that's why according to
mark cuban the non-genius billionaire
it's fine for china to commit genocide
they're good customers says mark cuban
but when he takes a different position
he's disgusted by it
he wants to take a knee that's how awful
this country is
if they were taking the knee and they
were being respectful i'd be proud of
them
you know hopefully you know i joined
them because i think we've learned a lot
since 2017 i think we've evolved as a
country
and this is really a unique point in
time where we can grow as a society we
can grow as a country and become far
more inclusive
well this week in the name of
inclusivity
and making china happy but when you
include people it almost always means
excluding them
mark cuban has decided that the national
anthem could no longer be played before
any home game
in dallas the nba initially supported
this decision
but this afternoon the nba changed its
mind the league released a statement
quote all teams will play the national
anthem in keeping with long-standing
league policy
will kane is the co-host of fox and
friends weekend we're happy to have him
on
tonight will good to see you thanks time
so it seems to me
the nba could have said you know it's
not just long-standing policy we
you know we kind of appreciate the
country where our sport was invented
and that sustains us why not take the
chance to kind of defend america in the
face of the attack on it
because that would be unfashionable
tucker the fashionable point of view and
the one
that mark cuban seems to have adopted
perhaps because some of his employees
hold this point of view perhaps some of
his players hold this point of view but
it's certainly a radical point of view
is that america is irredeemably flawed
that we're defined by our original sin
of slavery and the residual racism and
so it's fashionable to believe
that america's symbols her flag her
national anthem therefore are
politically divisive of course you and i
know that's not true i think most people
know
that's not true that the united states
is a unique experiment in human history
we're defined by our aspirations
our goals by our documents like the
constitution and ultimately tucker we
know those are unifying
elements unifying symbols but mark seems
to have adopted this idea
and it's totally dictated by the terms
of the left
that the united states its symbols are
divisive that we see the worst in
america and therefore we must cancel
all of these symbols that the rest of us
see as our aspirations and our unifying
factors that's why they won't take a
principled stand
i think that's really smart and nicely
expressed i mean those
symbols amount to our culture and our
culture is the only thing that unites us
i mean without a common culture
what do we have at that point right
and i'll tell you something more than
that part of that culture is sports i
love sports tucker if you know anything
about me you know i came from the world
of sports
i believe it brings us together across
racial barriers across socioeconomic
barriers
we arbitrarily root for these ridiculous
jerseys and laundry that we grew up
around
i love the mavericks by the way i'm
coming to you live from dallas i'm from
the dfw
area i'm a lifelong mavericks fan i
suffered through the 90s
i celebrated the dirk years i'm excited
about luka doncic if mark is watching
i'm a true heartfelt fan of the dallas
mavericks but if you make me
choose between the united states of
america and the mavericks it will not be
a hard choice
man nicely put will it's good to see you
tonight thank you for coming on
thanks tucker